[Musique]
françois bayrou bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes au coeur de l'actualité politique
quelle majorité pour un nouveau mandat
d' emmanuel macron qu'elle roule pour
vous quelles réponses aux conservateurs
et aux nationalistes qui sont à
l'offensive
actuellement pas mou d'abord sur l'air
du temps c'est un peu un doyen de la
politique française et j'ai été un
benjamin pendant longtemps à l'horaire
les benjamins de vienne et doyen c'est
la reine quand il dure quand il lui
aurait évité à la visée l'art de la
politique c'est de durer et mais terni
un conservateur on parlera des
conservateurs dans un instant l'air du
temps comment vous le trouvez là en ce
moment
je trouve que ce que nous vivons est
incroyablement révélateur
comme si pendant
des années et des années tous savaient
fermenté
souterrainement à bas bruit comme disent
les médecins et puis que tout d'un coup
ça explose
la lumière
est que ce qui explose à bien des égards
mérite qu'on fasse attention
il ya eu
moi ce qui me frappe c'est
la seule toute légitimité sont remises
en cause toutes les autorités sont
remises en cause alors c'est une
histoire qui vient de loin ça a commencé
par la religion qui a été qui a dominé
le système de valeurs et l'autorité
jusqu'à dominer le pouvoir politique ou
en tout cas à fonder le pouvoir
politique
première remise en cause deuxième remise
en cause les politiques eux mêmes et
alors ça qu'est-ce qu'ils prennent on a
l'habitude mais ça mérite quand même
qu'on le note troisième remise en cause
c'est vous les journalistes le pouvoir
médiatique
qui sont ciblés faut entendre ce qui se
dit vous dans les manifestations et il y
avait une mise en cause qui était pas
encore qui n'avait pas encore été
appelé c'étaient les scientifiques et
particulièrement les médecins alors il
ya toulouse est que faisait le
l'unanimité ou en tout cas on
considérait que c'était intouchable et
d'avoir vu sur vos plateaux les médecins
s'écharper entre eux
ce vilain pendait sa ruine et le dernier
socle le dell le dernier étage de la
légitimité on va parler de l'ambition
fassiez vous rire la légitimité on va
parler de toutes ces passions souvent
excessive est-ce que l'heure du centre a
sonné dans l'autre camp certains visent
deux grands partis déraisonnable est-ce
que l'heure du centre la loutre a sonné
c'est pas si raisonnable et le bon mot
parce que moi je crois qu'il faut de la
passion de l'engagement que qu'il faut
du courage qu'il faut de l'audace qu'il
faut du rire quand on a besoin de rire
et qu'il faut avoir de l'émotion quand
on en a besoin mais vous avez écouté
votre femme va j'ai écouté votre
émission avant que nous arrivions ici
les et les élections allemandes viennent
de se jouer au centre c'était le titre
du monde hier et c'était en fait le sens
souterrain de tout ce que vous indiquez
dans dans l'émission ça vous fait rêver
ça franchement c'est ça la perspective
aujourd'hui pour vous non je pense que
on met dans un univers vous l'avez
décrit dans lequel on a
concurrencé assauts de radicalité les
deux noeuds on dit des mots qu'on
n'aurait même pas imaginer dire il ya
encore un an ou deux on évoque des
réalités qui sont en réalité de deux
prises violente du pouvoir de gens qui
veulent à tout prix imposer leur loi aux
autres dépositions mardon qui vous ont
choqué la la question des prénoms dans
la bouche d'eric zemmour vous y est
prévenus c'est pas moi qui l'amène dans
votre discours est aujourd'hui arrêté
que je finisse lavalloise et puis je
sais que ce trade très agaçant pour
journée aller plus loin et c'était leur
loi et enfin j'ai par exemple eu en face
de soi un type qui veut finir ses
phrases et donc mais
je pense que ce qu'il faut devant ces
effondrements successifs c'est retrouver
du sens que nous puissions partager en
simple et s'il y a une fonction
des politiques responsables président de
la république c'est de donner aux gens
des raisons de vivre ensemble alors je
reviens à cette histoire de prénoms si
vous voulez puisque vous m'interrogez
sur ce point c'est dingue
il ya quelqu'un qui a fait ça au 20e
siècle c'est le maréchal ce train
réputation parce qu'il a spolié son
peuple fédé des centaines et centaines
et milliers de morts avec une clé nos
phobies dans un autre sens volume avec
l'axé 9e avec l'affirmation mobutu de
son nom de naissance il s'appelait
joseph puis il a dit ça ce n'est pas
possible qu'un africain porte un prénom
juif c'est une déclaration je ne je ne
déforme en rien sa déclaration mobutu
zemmour ça lui ira droit au coeur en mon
ami oui et il dit ça n'est pas possible
qu'une jeune fille africaine s'appelle
chantal ou marie 1 et je dis ça alors
que dans la république démocratique du
congo il ya 60 pour tant de chrétiens
catholiques
vouloir se mêler d'interdire à des gens
français de donner le prénom qu'il
souhaite le prénom de leur histoire ou
de leurs simplement de leur affection un
de mes meilleurs amis
président de l'université de pau adjoint
à la mairie s'appelle mohammad damas
c'est un mathématicien de premier rang
vous vous imaginez
que dans la cour de récréation on puisse
dire à ses enfants ton père il porte un
nom qui n'est pas français ce qui me ce
qui me frappe dans cette incroyable
dérapages voulu il cherche à toucher
quelque chose qui est qui brûle ce qui
me frappe c'est que pense pas la cour de
récréation mais françois bayrou dénonce
à bayon pardon je vous laisse pas fini
pour elle mais quand même pour faire
écho à ce que pense un certain nombre de
français est-ce qu'il ya pas une peur
réelle d'une société qui est devenue
trop métissée au point où il ya une
forme de dosage qui a pu exister dans le
passé qui n'est plus respectée la
question si vous permettez je trouve que
c'est une autre question je j'accepte
qu'on dit qu'on la traite mais je trouve
que en agitant
ses passions la ces choses brûlante en
faisant flamber en versant de l'essence
sur tous les feux qui traînent on se
rend pas compte de ce que vont être les
victimes les plus fragiles quand on sait
ce qu'est la cruauté d'une cour de
récréation
quand on sait ce que c'est la
persécution le le harcèlement ça veut
dire pardon il quelque chose d'inhumain
dans cette position oui à quelque chose
de d'une trahison de ce que la france
est et ce qui me stupéfait c'est que on
laisse vous aussi on laisse dire ces
choses sans s'en émouvoir françois
vaillant comme si c'était mon comme si
on était entré dans un temps on peut
dire absolument n'importe quoi dans sa
base bardou quelques églises on ne va
pas me dit on et eric zemmour n'est pas
seulement une créature médiatique non il
ya eu jamais d'une réponse populaire
quand on le voit que dans ses émissions
suivi par des centaines de milliers de
personnes ça c'est pas une créature peur
des invitations médiatique c'est une
réalité voyez quand on voit des
programmes sur des sujets ultra
conservateur qui ont un tel succès il ya
visiblement une envie de droite ou de
conservatisme en france qui est là est
ce que ça vous le reconnaissez vous
voyez c'est ça qui vous épate l'audience
non mais c'est qu'au final on en parle
on en fait conduit à une votation les
gens votent quand il ya une élection
rime mais là c'est jean vaz une élection
et les gens élisent avec leur école en
tout cas ça les intéresse vous voyez que
vous que vous vous transposez dans la
démocratie dans le débat et dans le
choix vos histoires d'audience vos
histoires d'audimat
c'est ça qui vous épate moi ça m'épate
pas j'ai une seule chose en tête quand
quelque chose est bon je le soutiens
quand c'est mauvais je vais à l'encontre
et vous dites
conservatisme c'est pas du conservatisme
il ya des choses à conserver je suis
absolument j'ai été ministre de
l'éducation nationale suffisamment pour
savoir que on doit transmettre des
choses précieuses mais ça c'est pas du
conservatisme c'est de la trahison de ce
que la france a toujours été ensemble la
trahison de ce que nous avons de plus
précieux de plus de plus fondamental
qui est que la france ça n'est pas une
religion ça n'est pas une couleur de
peau ce n'est pas une origine la france
c'est l'adhésion à un idéal
que dire pardon que dire je reviens à
cela à y avait aujourd'hui c'est journée
du conservatisme ça n'a évidemment pas
tout l'opinion mais c'est partie de
l'opinion qui est preneuse vous dirais
que c'est l'audience oui mais le
programme qui aurait paru impensable et
quelques années sur samba rbo sainte
eulalie une sorte de retour à des
valeurs très conservatrices en matière
de moeurs aussi qu'est ce que vous lui
dites à cette france là eh bien je dis
que vous pardon je prenais pas mal ça et
je veux je dis je dis que vous voulez
c'est à voir
parce que vous prenez les mots qu'on
vous propose ou qu'on vous impose
il ne s'agit pas de conservatisme
de l'essentiel de la france il s'agit
quoi lorgner vers le dévoiement ckoi
réactionnaire c'est quoi à quel moment
vous mettez xénophobes et réactionnaires
analyser quel arrêt actionnaires parce
que ça n'aurait jamais existé quoi ça
n'a existé qu'à une époque horrible et
donc je ne je ne veux pas l'évoquer
laquelle qui est le pétainisme la
deuxième guerre mondiale à face eu ce
genre de choses que zemmour c'est le
pétainiste bord ou non ces mots tu
défends pétain 1 sur le sur la sphère
des juifs dont il a sauvé des juifs dit
il c'est immoral de dire ça
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous c'est
moi qui vous pose des questions
retournez pas on met face à face
marchands non non non mais soyons
sérieux vous poser des questions
vraiment sérieux si quelqu'un ne voit
pas que la tentative de réhabilitation
de pétain 1 sur le drame juif est une
déstabilisation de notre mémoire
collective que des juifs aient été
livrés et zemmour disent pas grave
c'était des juifs étrangers d'abord
c'est pas vrai
parce que la rafle du vel d'hiv c'était
pas des juifs étrangers n'est ce pas
mais que que quelqu'un ose dire que
livrer des juifs étrangers c'est moins
grave que de livrer des juifs français
mais à quoi ça sert que qu'on soit allé
à l'école à quoi ça sert que on est
enseigné les grands auteurs et les les
philosophes et les poètes et victor hugo
et peggy à quoi ça sert ça n'est pas du
conservatisme c'est une trahison vous
êtes chrétien démocrate
démocrates-chrétiens ont parlé dans gala
merkel c'est cette tradition le mot
chrétien dieu sait si en politique
maintenant beaucoup n'osent plus
l'utiliser vous vous dites je suis là
comme chrétien ça vous choque aussi je
n'aime pas mélanger la police la
politique et la retraite français ça
vous voyez langue à la marcal qui au
contraire dit en fonction de mes
convictions chrétiennes j'ai accueilli
des migrants c'est la loi impose maïs
est complètement différent il faut que
vous inscriviez votre religion sur les
registres des bureaux de vote sur les
sur les registres des listes électorales
vous vous déclarez comme étant d'une
religion enfante c'est pas ça je suis
heureux que ça ne soit pas ça cela dit
je ne fuis pas
je suis croyant même comme on dit
pratiquants françois bayrou pour
répondre à ce courant là dont on a bien
compris combien vous vous y opposer
quelle est la force aujourd'hui de ce
qu'on peut appeler le centre la maison
présidentielle la maison commune on voit
que les choses sont en train de bouger
est ce que le temps d'un grand parti
centriste est venu selon
j'emploie jamais l'adjectif centriste
mais le temps
d'un d'un grand parti central qui
reprend toutes ces traditions qui ont
toutes ou presque le mot démocrates dans
leur un social-démocrate démocrates
chrétiens
libéraux démocrates libéraux moi je dit
humaniste parce que c'est ça le sait ça
le fondement emmanuel macron est selon
vous le la tête de ce mouvement là dans
tous les cas elle en est la figure
aujourd'hui parce que parce qu'il est le
porte drapeau parce qu'ils exercent des
responsabilités et parce que
profondément
c'est quelqu'un qui vit
ces choses là c'est ces inquiétudes la
et ces valeurs là et quel sera votre
auront la volonté alors c'est avec eux
qu'il a été
le collaborateur d'un très grand
philosophe faudrait que ces valeurs la
peur
comme ça qui vit alors je dirais
c'est un démocrate spiritualiste
simplifiée et donc démocrate ou
républicain ce qui revient sur ce sujet
à peu près au même on a un idéal qui
nous permet de vivre
un pays ça n'est pas seulement une
collection de gens qui sont qui ont les
mêmes papiers d'identité c'est une
communauté de gens qui ont le même idéal
mais françois bayrou vous êtes un
politicien ses magrets pour savoir qu'il
faut encore organiser tout ça en partie
je suis pas madre il y en a beaucoup et
il ya l'art m il ya votre mouvement le
modem il y a maintenant edouard philippe
qui va lancer son mouvement c'est le
moment de citer saint-jean l'évangile
selon saint jean il ya beaucoup de
maisons dans la demeure du père est ce
que là il y en a pas un peu trop
exactement oui c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut simplifier ces
organisations les rassembler leur donner
une identité commune permettre aux
français d'adhérer à ce à ce grand
mouvement
républicain démocrate qui fait que que
qu'on n'est pas indifférent est ce que
ça veut dire soyons très concrets que la
raim la république en marche telle
qu'elle existait a vécu selon nous
tenons je ne veux pas prononcé ce jean
d'oukases la république en marche je
sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens sévère à
leur endroit ça n'est pas mon cas parce
que j'ai moi essayer enfin j'ai
constitué avec le modem mouvement
démocrate
un parti nouveau en 2007
si vous saviez ce qu'on en a bavé
c'est le le le démon qui touchent les
forces politiques c'est le démon de la
division dans l'adn de la politique il
n'ya qu'une chose qui revient
perpétuellement c'est chacun joue pour
lui même voilà mais pour l'instant elle
est là la division si edouard philippe
créer un mouvement en dehors pour
l'instant c'est son projet est-ce que
selon vous c'est une erreur
je ne mêle pas de décision de mes amis
mais est ce que ce serait mieux qu'ils
ne le fassent pas en tout cas je veux
dire une chose
si ne soyez pas si prudent
mais c'est le social mieux qu'ils soient
dans votre maison vous rendez à l'heure
de votre maison c'est très compliqué
quand même question d'ennemis dans la
vie comme au frère encore pour
maintenant vous avez l'âge on peut
parler librement non mais franchement
est ce qu ils doivent y allons réunir
dans ce grand mouvement central toutes
ses sensibilités et toutes ces chapelles
des chapelles les français ne peuvent
même plus les comprendre où les entendre
il n'y a que les spécialistes de
sciences politiques et les journalistes
avaient retiré attaque de la l1 tout
cette formation si toit de cette maison
commune vous l pardon pourquoi de cette
maison commune vous est selon vous le
représentant nature tout ne m'avait pas
laissée mal finir ma phrase elle était
pourtant très imprévisible la phrase que
j'allais dire j'allais dire une fois que
cette maison est constituée ou en même
temps que nous la constitution qui veut
venir sera le bienvenu qui veut
participer à cette construction à cet
ensemble à ce rassemblement de bonne
volonté parce que ça qu'il s'agit et de
bonne volonté pour qu'elles pour
l'intérêt général et pour les combats
qui viennent et pour les générations qui
viennent parce que je n'ai jamais pour
ma part penser qu un parti ça devait
être pour un homme un parti c'est un
courant profond comme vous l'avez décrit
à très juste titre c'est c'est une
philosophie c'est une vision du monde et
c'est des gens qui s'associent pour leur
faire avancer quand on se rappelle 2017
votre rencontre avec emmanuel macron une
forme de pacte ça a tenu bien ou mal
plus ou moins enfin sa tenue vous êtes
là toujours de toujours nécessaire lui
était nécessaire dans cette majorité à
venir qu'est ce qu'il incarne pour vous
historiquement maintenant on voit à quel
point vous parliez tout à l'heure on
parlait du mouvement conservateur les
choses bougent de tous les côtés
qu'est-ce qu'il est selon vous emmanuel
macron emmanuel macron 7,1 c'est un
démocrate français
avec un sens profond
du sens que l'engagement politique a
encore une fois j'ai parlé de de sa
vocation de philosophie
c'est exactement ça et c'est
deuxièmement une chose
qui n'est pas souvent dit c'est
quelqu'un qui est profondément ému
devant les
personnes plus souvent les jeunes qui
n'ont pas l'avenir qu'il mériterait
il a deux de ce point de vue là ce a
toujours gouvernés il dit vous ne devez
pas être assigné à résidence
c'est pas parce que vous êtes né dans un
quartier que vous devez être à jamais
condamné par la fatalité à être écarté
du travail de la reconnaissance
de la réussite et ça c'est quelque chose
qui le touche profondément c'est un
aspect social de sa de sa sensibilité
françois bayrou écoutons toujours
l'autre camp confrontation des idées
quand on vous entend depuis le début
vous incarnez ce qu'on a longtemps
appelé les élites trou voire politique
vous savez des oui non mais ça je sais
bien mais aussi pour ça élites
républicaines très grave y voilà lexar
par la culture le grec le latin culture
très traditionnel dans l'autre camp ceux
qui parlent de conservatisme aujourd'hui
eux disent précisément les élites ont
lâché ça qu'est ce que c'est le grec et
latin pendant les écoles en france plus
grand chose qu'est ce que c'est la
tradition tout l'enseignement des
grandes traditions écoles grand chose
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à ceux
là ceux qui disent vous avez profité
tout ça la nouvelle génération celle
acculturation je leur ai dégradation
inde et que puis je leur réponds depuis
des années vous avez laissé faire
vous avez laissé se décomposer sont vos
yeux sans rien dire en ricanant eu ce
qu'était le le corps de 2,2 ce que la
france avait de plus précieux
les hussards noirs de la république
comme on disait les les maîtres d'école
les écoles normales vous avez laissé
diminué ça quand j'ai été ministre
on a multiplié
par dix le nombre des élèves qui à poney
le latin et le grec j'ai fait on ne
reste pas grand-chose pardon soyons
francs les écoles françaises aujourd'hui
25 ans il en reste quand même pas mal en
latin faut quand même pas et latin c'est
la langue mère un fait bon vous avez
laissé faire
dans tous les domaines il ya une étude
tout à fait passionnante qui vient de
sortir par un sociologue vous avez
peut-être reçu qui s'appelle eric morain
ça s'appelle 3 il ya trois textes sur
l'école républicaine
et il raconte avec des chiffres de
sociologues précis que quand j'ai pris
la décision
d'interdire le voile à l'école en une
seule année à l'école parce que l'école
il n'y a pas d'autres lois à l'école que
la loi du savoir
en une seule année
le résultat des filles
2 de cette origine d'origine musulmane
le résultat des filles au bac a augmenté
de 25%
on est passé de moins de 50 % à plus de
65% en une seule année et ils disent ça
c'était de l'émancipation et il ajoute
c'est pas un texte qu'on a voté plus
tard une loi c'est cette circulaire qui
a libéré ces jeunes filles et qui leur a
permis de
de réussir quelque chose qu'elle
n'aurait pas pu réussir autrement merci
beaucoup françois bayrou vous étiez
coriace a interviewé ce soir vous avez
la niaque comme on dit oui oui mais vous
savez je suis plutôt d'un peuple de
rugby si vous savez que que pau a battu
montpellier hier c'est peut-être ce
moment c'est cette excitation ses
félicitations à pau ça cet échange ça
veut dire que l'on regarde dans la
campagne à venir celle d' emmanuel
macron 2022 au jour et un rôle je trouve
des premiers je ferai comme toujours ce
que je peux que je dois et tout ce que
je peux et les centristes ils ont été
beaucoup déçu à chaque fois on dit les
centres l'ouverture et cetera mitterrand
95 des histoires à chaque fois ça marche
pas qu'est ce qui va changer cette fois
ça dépend s'ils sont à leur compte ou
s'ils veulent être une route secours
s'ils choisissent d'être une roue de
secours ils sont éliminés peut-être vous
avez pas vu mais hier l air qui disait
toujours le candidat de la droite et du
centre avait avec des traits d'union
entre le candidat de la droite et du
centre a décidé que les adhérents des
partis centristes qui était leur allié
minoritaire n'aurait pas le droit de
vote pour changer pour choisir le long
dans le var pour vous d'après vous non
je mettrai ça je dis pas ça je dis
justesse d'engagement on n'est pas là
pour se faire plaisir on n'est pas là
pour un avantage personnel on est là
parce que ce qui va se jouer et vous le
savez bien est absolument capital merci
beaucoup françois bayrou